they are your comrades your compatriots
your brothers in arms when a tank start
rolling in the guns start roaring you
want only the best the brightest and the
most skilled crew driving your tank to
victory
crews are essential to success in World
of Tanks every tank needs a crew to
operate it or it will not be able to
roll out to battle each time you
purchase a new tank you will be prompted
to assign a crew to that tank you will
be able to see the crews mastery in
their respective tank above the
commander's picture though you are free
to select any crew you wish your best
option will be highlighted for you
reassigning a crew from one of your
existing tanks requires retraining
sending your crew to tank Academy for
gold will train them to 100% mastery
sending them to regimental school for
silver will train them to eighty percent
mastery reassigning a crew to a tank
class that they have not been trained in
will be more expensive than keeping them
in their current class of training and
reassigning a crew to a higher tier will
be more expensive than reassigning them
to a tank of the same tier when you
reassign a crew to a tank the existing
crew in that tank will be kicked out
crews belonging to a particular country
can only be reassigned to tanks from
their own country hiring a new crew is
only available after you purchase a new
tank should you choose to hire a new
crew they too will have to be trained
because this crew is new and
inexperienced you will have a third
option for their training rapid courses
though it costs nothing to put a crew
through rapid courses there will only be
trained to fifty percent mastery leaving
you to make up the rest on the
battlefield you may find it is much more
advantageous to transfer a more
experienced crew that is already in your
roster each time you take a crew out to
battle they will become more and more
proficient in their particular tank once
the crew reaches 100 percent mastery in
their tank you will be able to select
skills and perks for them skills and
perks are valuable abilities that will
drastically improve your cruise
performance while skills and perks share
some similarities there are a few
differences when you select a skill for
your crew they will begin training on it
much in the same way they did when
training on their tank as your crews
mastery with a particular
Gill increases the skills effectiveness
in battle will increase the camouflage
skill at seventy-five percent mastery
for example will do a better job of
concealing your tank from prying eyes
than it would at twenty percent mastery
once the skill reaches 100 percent you
will be able to train your crew in a
second skill you can continue to train
your crew and skills one at a time until
they have up to 25 different skills be
sure to read the descriptions for each
skill and select the best skills for
your play style perks much like skills
are a goal for your crew to work towards
by earning experience in battle unlike
skills however a perk does not activate
at all until it reaches 100% mastery
once it does activate you will
immediately be able to reap the rewards
as with skills be sure to read the
descriptions of each perk and decide
which are best for your play style if
you reassign a crew that has a set of
active perks and skills but opted not to
send it to tank Academy in their new
tank their skills and perks will be
deactivated until they reach 100%
mastery once again you can opt to
dismiss a crew completely if you wish
however doing so will completely remove
the crew including the experience perks
and skills they have gained make
absolutely sure you want to do this
because once you dismiss a crew it is
gone forever while reassigning a crew to
a regular tank will cost either gold or
silver it will cost you nothing to
reassign a crew into or out of a premium
tank any crew reassigned to a premium
tank will also enjoy the tanks benefits
of accelerated training once your crew
has utilized those accelerated training
benefits you can also reassign them back
into the tank they came from for free
provided the tank has remained without a
crew however if you want to transfer the
crew out of the premium tank and into a
new tank you will have to retrain them
your tank can't
function without a crew take the time to
properly train your crews and assign
them the best perks and skills for
battle and you will have the advantage
over your adversaries